if the Bible say anything about saying
the same prayer over and over so many
times
we're getting some very direct questions
and we want to give you correct answers
from the scriptures themselves
themselves I want to turn to the book of
Saint Matthew and I'm going to look at
chapter 6 I believe it is give me a
moment to see if I can find it Matthew
chapter 6 and then we look at verse 7
and this is what the Bible says now you
want an answer this is written in red
these are the words of Christ the Bible
says but when you pray use not vain
repetitions as the Heathen do for they
think they shall be heard for their much
speaking
should I redo the game
not necessary to say the same little
prayer 50 times 75 times or whatever the
Bible says when you pray use not vain
repetition as the Heathen do for they
think they shall be heard for they are
much speaking those are the words of
Christ next please
and this person's making reference to
Mark 16 12 did Jesus take more than one
form
no we don't have any record that he did
Jesus was incarnated in human flesh and
thus limited by human flesh he was
thought to be a ghost simply because the
disciples didn't know who he was from a
distance next place Pastor what if
you're dating someone who is not a
Believer what should we do besides pray
well you're taking a big chance doing
that in the first place the Bible
actually forbids it I don't think people
understand anymore what God really
expects of them but a Christian has a
prescribed course it's found in the word
of God and God expects a Christian to
follow that word would somebody say Amen
to that I'm reading second Corinthians
chapter 6 verse 14 be ye not unequally
yoked together with unbelievers for what
Fellowship hath righteousness with
unrighteousness and what communion hath
light with Darkness one of the most
serious things you will ever do on Earth
is to choose a mate and get married
you need the help of God even when
you're doing it in the church
would somebody say Amen it is supremely
dangerous for our believer to date
romantically get involved with an
unbeliever not only that it is forbidden
by scripture next
this is interesting what about UFOs are
they for real and if they are not what
are they and who are they some who come
off and know we get repeat questions it
simply means that the person probably
was not there there is a text in the
Bible it says as we near the end of time
fearful sight shall be seen from heaven
now I must tell you that the government
studies UFOs most of them I understand
are identified there's some that they
can't figure out
there are some that are the figments of
people's Lively imaginations
sometimes an airplane these have to do
with physical law sometimes an airplane
or something like that can be
approaching at a certain angle and light
bounces off it in such a way that makes
it appear spherical or as something that
it is not usually they are identified
when they don't know what they are they
simply say they don't know and if they
don't know I don't know
Dr Brooks this is interesting did job
lose his first wife when he lost
everything that he had when everything
was restored back to him were the
children born as babies or did they come
back as grown people
well we have no record that job got a
divorce we think it's the same wife not
only that but the children were babies
they didn't come back from the dead the
Bible says the Dead return no more and
that pertained in that day as well as
today next please
Pastor if I was baptized once by
immersion in a Baptist Church should I
be baptized again the same way in
another church no we deliberately took
our time with that the other night
baptism is a sign of an outward an
outward sign of an inward cleansing
baptism says to the world this is my
starting place by faith doing what the
Lord wants me to do and we read to you
from Acts chapter 18 where a man by the
name of Apollos a man by the name of
Apollos went to Ephesus and the Bible
gives you a very fine Commendation
concerning this man he was instructed in
the way of the Lord favored in the
spirit spake and taught diligently the
things of the Lord but he was limited in
his knowledge he knew only the baptism
of John eventually as you read on down
in the context Apollos left and went to
Corinth and Saint Paul came to Ephesus
where he had been and Paul on certain
disciples the Bible says that's verse 1
of chapter 19. he found disciples
converted people who were following all
the light they knew is that clear I want
to make that very clear they were
following all the light they knew and
they were the children of God Paul said
to them have you received the Holy Ghost
since you believed and they said we've
not so much as heard whether there be in
the Holy Ghost
here they were limited but they were not
rebellious they were not following
because they had not been taught is that
clear come on answer me is that clear
they were doing all they had been taught
and when you do all you know you are a
child of God and as surely as you're
born God will send you full knowledge
sooner or later so Paul then said unto
them under what then were you baptized
they said unto John's baptism then said
Paul verse 4 apparently John baptized
with the baptism of repentance saying
unto the people that they should believe
on him which should come after him that
is on Christ in other words their focus
was John the Baptist Jesus they hadn't
really heard about yet and the baptism
that he set an example in in the baptism
of the Holy Ghost
so the Bible says verse 5 when they
heard this they were baptized now these
were Christians these were God's people
that is and they were baptized already
re-baptism was not a denial of their
faith it was an addition being
recognized to their faith full knowledge
had come and they were baptized again
would you say Amen
doesn't mean that your first experience
was invalid it simply meant when full
Light Came you made full commitment and
surrender because of your faith in God
when you do that you're baptized again
baptism is the door to God's room the
church next Pastor I once heard someone
say if you put children in Christian
Schools they don't learn how to deal in
the real world therefore is it better
for them to be in public school I know
the Bible teaches train up a child in
the way he should go and when he's old
he'll not depart from it knowledge of
the real world
is what causes our young people to be so
delinquent today
would somebody say Amen
knowledge of the real world is what has
corrupted our young people
they are things you know you can see how
old I am
and there are things that are utterly
shocking to me today especially amongst
our youth they are irritating thoughts
and practices that I never dreamed of
when I was a teenager you need something
to counter this
wherever I go I find people even the
church who figure they gotta know about
the world in order to avoid it God told
Adam and Eve don't eat of the tree of
knowledge of Good and Evil and we are
told it was never God's will that they
should even know what evil was I want to
read you a text that I remember
preaching on a long time ago if I can
get to it very quickly Romans chapter 16
and verse 19. I want you to listen to
this there are people who think I've got
to see it all in order to avoid it you
see it all you might become Enchanted
and then entrapped
somebody was trying to defend these
filthy movies they said but Pastor
Brooks it's just life
and I said when you see the putrifying
body of a dead dog on the highway
rottening and stinking that's life too
but you don't pay six dollars for a
chair and sit and watch it for two hours
we are supposed to have delicate
sensibilities
now listen the Bible says in Romans 16
and verse 19 for your obedience has come
abroad unto all men I am glad therefore
on your behalf but yet I would have you
Wise Wise unto that which is good and
simple concerning evil
why is concerning good simple meaning
you don't know very much
young people today are too sophisticated
and sophistication implies experience
and people like that can't blush
next please
pastor this is signed a Jewish Christian
the Bible says that God created the
world in six days and he re he rested on
the seventh day so doesn't that mean the
Sabbath starts at midnight Friday and
ends at midnight Saturday so we're just
rushing a little bit a good question a
sincere question and we haven't had it
before when God created the world he did
not make watches
good night
at midnight you're supposed to be asleep
and the Bible says
the Bible says the evening and the
morning were the first day by evening
and the morning where now this is God's
plan
this is not Jewish there were no Jews
when Adam and Eve were created by
evening and the morning were the third
day fourth day fifth day sixth day and
seventh day now let me read to you what
the Bible says in Leviticus 23 and I'm
going to read verse 32 it better be
because that's the one I remember
Leviticus 23 32 and listen this is what
it says
Leviticus 23 and verse 32
it shall be unto you a Sabbath of rest
ye shall afflict your souls
from evening unto evening shall you
celebrate your Sabbath would you say
amen and over in Mark 1 and verse 32 the
Bible says at evening when the sun did
set now let's connect this the evening
and the morning made the day God did not
Mate watches and clocks he made the son
to Rule the Day and the moon to rule the
night the Bible says and so for all of
these centuries believers who know have
observed the day from evening unto
evening not midnight to midnight this is
something happen when the when
expediency came in and when folk wanted
to spend their nights doing various
things the church began to teach from
Midnight to midnight that's not what God
taught it says from evening and evening
shall you celebrate your Sabbath and
Mark 1 32 says at evening when the sun
did set that's what the Bible teaches
that's what I believe and teach next
week Dr Brooks how do you know when you
are saved some teach that you must speak
in tongues in order to be saved they
also teach speaking in tongues is the
evidence that you're filled with the
Holy Ghost I guess the question is about
tongues of it nowhere in the Bible do
you read that you have to speak in
tongues to get the holy God Bible
doesn't say that it says in Acts 5 32
and we are his Witnesses of these things
and so is also the Holy Ghost whom God
hath given to them that obey him to whom
to them to him
that will obey God gives the Holy Ghost
now let me read you something in First
Corinthians chapter 13 of course you've
read that though I speak with the
tongues of men and of angels and have
not charity I am but a sounding brass
and a tingling symbol look how many
tongues you speak in if you don't have
charity what's charity
Jesus said If You Love Me Do what
and if you don't do that you're just a
sounding brass and a tinkling symbol in
chapter 14 Paul gives an exegesis on
tongues because this confusion had
Arisen in koreth and Paul said some
powerful things here he that speaketh in
an unknown tongue edifieth himself but
he that prophesieth edifiet the church I
would that you all speak with tongues
but rather that ye prophesy for great is
he that prophesieth that he that
speaketh in tongues except he interpret
except what
that the church may receive edifying
Paul is saying if you've got something
to say in an unknown tongue let somebody
tell the church what you're saying it
does not happen in this modern I want to
be very kind
but in this modern deception it does not
happen
nobody interprets now Paul says in verse
6 now Brethren if I come unto you
speaking with tongues what shall I
profit you except I shall speak to you
either by Revelation or by knowledge or
by prophesying or by Doctrine verse 8
for if the Trump had given uncertain
sound who shall prepare for battle
in other words Paul is saying I speak in
many times what is a tongue let me give
you a dictionary definition a tongue is
a language
a tongue is a language
a vehicle for conveying thought and
feeling
when you sit and listen to me you
understand what we're talking about now
if you're babbling and nobody
understands you are simply a distraction
in the service of the Lord and it says
not the trumpet give an uncertain sound
who shall prepare for battle
just like our army used to do blow the
Beagle the bugle blow the bugle when
they wanted men to prepare to charge or
for revelry or whatever men Knew by the
sound of the bugle what they were
supposed to do Paul uses that analogy if
you blow the trumpet and it gives an
uncertain sound nobody knows what the
world it means nobody will be alert
nobody will do what they ought to do
Paul goes on to say many things I don't
want to take time to read them all but
he said I speak in tongues more than ye
all this is verse 18. I thank God and
and forgive me I'll tell you I'll tell
you I'm struggling with a bad cold
forget it now that I've told you verse
18 I thank God I speak with tongues more
than ye all verse 19 yet in the church
I'd rather speak five words with my
understanding that by my voice I might
teach others also than ten thousand
words in an unknown tongue would you say
amen I think in one place Paul says if
everybody stands up speaking in tongues
people will say aren't they mad and
that's what they sound like insane
people
and that's the language of this
particular chapter If any man verse 27
If any man speaking in unknown tongue
Let It Be by two or at the most by three
and that by course and let one interpret
what do you mean if I'm the preacher and
I can only speak English and then I need
come here Lord come a minute
and let's say that we got a lot of dear
Spanish people here and we do and let's
say we have some that don't understand
English at all here's the way we're
supposed to do it I want you to
interpret for me beloved I'm glad to be
here
I believe in the Lord Jesus Christ
he is our only hope of Salvation
Salvador
that is the gift of tongues in the
church did you what I said
you understood me who speak English our
Spanish folk understood him now I've
been to places where you have two one on
each side I was in South Africa and a a
Zulu was on one side another sutu on the
other side and if I would say beloved
Jesus is coming soon then I'd wait on
this man and that man now the Bible says
if you are going to do that Let It Be by
two and at most by three don't have too
many doing it because by the time they
all say you will have forgotten what you
were talking about
[Applause]
um maybe we'll deal with this a little
further later on but Paul said let all
things be done decently and in order God
is not the author of confusion it's
right here in this chapter
he's not the author of confusion what
they talk about today as tongues is
merely Babble a deception of the enemy
now I know that there are those who are
sincere and I never belittle sincerity
but God sends truth to Enlighten those
who are sincere would you say Amen one
last point it's in here Paul said that
if you're going to speak in tongues you
got to have an interpreter he said
tongues are a sign
for those on the outside of the church
but prophecy is is for those inside now
they got it twisted the other way around
if you go to a church where they do this
and you say what are they saying or they
say you can't understand it this is only
for the church the Bible says tongues
are assigned to the outside as on the
day of Pentecost when God gave 12
unlearned men
the gift of tongues the gift of
linguistics in an instant and they went
out and began to preach and all those
folks were gathered from all of those
countries understood in their own
language it was a sign that something
special is happening here and 3 000
joined the church but when folks stand
up in church and they got a little
closed community and they battled in
tongues you please tell me what's the
good of it next person
this is from a 13 year old Bible student
why didn't Satan decide to follow God
when he knew what was right didn't he
have a chance before Christ died on the
cross
oh yes beloved Satan started in heaven
as an angel named Lucifer and the love
of God reached out to him the appeal of
God went out to him but he hardened his
heart I think the port to learn from
your question is you can persist in
doing wrong so long that you get to the
place God cannot reach you the Bible
says your conscience becomes seered that
means burned out
and there are people today that even
sociologists and psychologists are
saying are unconscionable they have no
conscience
anybody that can explode a truck and
kill babies
and Destroy secretaries and
no conscience demon-possessed Satan with
sofa he could no longer respond next
week
Pastor in Malachi 3 10 God said if we
pay our tithes and offerings he'd bless
us and there should not be room enough
to receive it why are most of us
struggling just to pay our bills and
Pastor I don't mean with credit cards
very interesting question
God promised blessings and I think
somebody here needs to know that
blessings are more than money
would you say Amen
you say we're struggling thank God
you've got enough Health to struggle
with
if God didn't bless you you couldn't
even do that
so let us not
speak this way concerning God and He
does keep his word can I get a witness
from somebody out there let me tell you
and we're going to preach about this
next week go ahead please One Church
teaches Jesus was born in Jerusalem but
King James version says he was born in
Bethlehem I believe the King James
version why would a church teach that
Jesus was born in Jerusalem I don't know
why would a church teach to the first
day of the Sabbath it's not in the Bible
why would they teach that the law has
done away with is not in the Bible
the Bible said not just the King James
but the Bibles say
that Jesus was born in Bethlehem and not
only that the Old Testament forecasted
hundreds of years before the fact Micah
5 2 and 7 next please our final question
please explain the difference between
trespasses sin and iniquity I did
enumerate those the other night and when
David offered his prayer he named all
three he said according to the multitude
of thy Tender Mercies blot out my
transgressions wash me throughly of my
iniquities and Purge me of my sin three
words they all are kin but they are
varying of varying severity
in the Greek the word for trespasses
means mistakes we make plenty of those
the one for sin homantino means to miss
the mock and iniquity is the worst one
the word to miss the mock
suggests shooting an arrow in a bowl now
this analogy will help you to understand
it
if you are totally unskilled and unused
to a bow and arrow and you miss the mark
That's trespass
if you have the strength to hit it and
you just miss it that's sin but if you
have the skill and the strength and you
deliberately miss it that's iniquity
iniquity is sinning against light
iniquity is sinning against knowledge
let me be very very very pertinent to
the times iniquity is sinning after CD
Brooks tells you
what the word of God says and you see it
you disobey God tomorrow and you know
better that's iniquity and that's the
worst what
why do some names have the same meanings
have some names have meanings this has
been a practice from the beginning of
time
uh when Adam and Eve had a child they
gave that child a name and those names
had meanings and today many people
simply copy names from other folk but if
you get to the bottom of it the names
have good meanings sometimes it is the
hope of the parrot that the name will
guide in the shaping of character
and sometimes it's interesting to know
what your name means how many of you
know what your name means raise your
head yeah well they're lots of people I
know what Charles means it means
lionhearted and courageous and I say to
myself I want to be like that next
please Dr Brooks who wanted the head of
John the Baptist
the daughter Salome danced for it the
mother was the one who wanted it her
name was erodius and her husband Herod
who was married to his brother's wife
and John the Baptist condemned it really
didn't want John to die but what a man
will do for a bad woman
a young person wants to know if Adam and
Eve had not sinned would we be in heaven
now the answer is no if Adam and Eve had
not sinned there would be no death and
no ruin on this Earth the reason we're
going to heaven is because God is going
to purify this Earth and make a new one
and then let us live here the meat shall
inherit the Earth had there been no sin
the family of Earth would have remained
right here and never death or
destruction next this person heard that
your conscience is a person and looks
the same way you do is that true that's
not true your conscience is not a person
it's a part of you the Bible says God
has dealt to every man a Measure of
Faith and that can be stretched to imply
that God has placed in your head a
conscience and that conscience tells you
what's right and what's wrong even
people who are not Christians know
what's right and wrong and you'll find
out tonight it's possible to abuse that
conscience so that it no longer speaks
to you next please someone wants to know
do you feel musical instruments are
wrong in the church
I certainly do not now I do realize that
there are those who teach that it's
wrong to have any kind of musical
instrument in church I don't know where
they get it if it were wrong you
wouldn't see that piano and you wouldn't
see that organ and that other
thingamajig that Christy plays over
there
the Bible tells us listen listen the
Bible tells us in Revelation chapter 14
and verse 2 that when we get to heaven
we're going to be able to play some
Harps now if they're going to have
musical instruments in heaven certainly
it's all right down here if those
instruments glorify God
and not sell next please
the other night Pastor you said that we
should assemble and worship together but
what if you disagree that things go with
things that go on in the church even
after expressing our concerns and
nothing seems to be done how can I in
good conscience be a part of that
assembly the truth is how can you in
good chance it's not be
you know if we were more reasonable and
thoughtful we'd understand that always
wherever God's people are Satan put some
folk in there to create problems
go back to the children of Israel they
were God's people and he said so and yet
there was hardly a more honorary Bunch
on Earth than they they murmured and
complained and bellyached all the time
they slipped into idolatry and it's
recorded over and over that the people
did evil in the sight of the Lord
now when Jesus came he chose 12
disciples and one of them was the devil
which one was it
I thought you'd say that the truth is
they all were
until they got converted
two of them were called sons of thunder
they wanted to call it on fire burn up
people Peter did what seems on the
surface to be worse than What Judas did
you see the church is not a resort full
of perfect people it's a hospital where
folk come to get better would you say
amen and these self-righteous people who
are too holy to go to church with some
who aren't
are having a problem that they need to
pray about
did not turn that off kindly
pastor this is a little involved I have
so many questions but most important to
me is this in order for children to
learn about God and have a chance for
salvation is it wrong for the one parent
who is also striving to separate or
divorce the spouse who is living a
verbally abusive drug-infested bad
tempered unstable irresponsible
lifestyle
oh this is
this reaches to the hot and tugs away
I get the impression not knowing who
these people are that somebody wants to
do right and wants our children to
develop character and they live with a
person apparently who
is out of control the seven of the enemy
what do you do
now let me be very clear on something
the Bible only gives us one basis or
grounds for divorce and that is
fornication what did I say
some people say adultery it actually
says fornication which is moral
uncleanness
moral uncleanness can include incest and
bestiality
and accepted before that God does not
allow us another basis for divorce but
there is I believe what we call
sometimes a law of Separation it's found
in Paul's writing to the writings to the
church at Corinth and He suggests that
if you depart you must remain unmarried
divorce is not easy God never intended
it to be God said he hates divorce there
are some situations that I would not
live under
and if I had to separate I would
and I would pray earnestly to be kept
and I believe his grace is sufficient to
do that next please Pastor as I witness
about the Sabbath to a friend and she's
trying to do right but doesn't want to
accept the Sabbath and it continues to
be a subject between us how shall I
handle it after showing her scripture
after scripture you can't convert
anybody I can either
the Holy Spirit converts people and I I
sometimes make it clear that you have a
choice and if you want to go to hell
help yourself it's easy
nobody can force you to do right the
Holy Spirit appeals and anybody wants to
can rebel against God
there comes a time when you ought to
stop talking and just live and pray next
please
Pastor Brooks where does your spirit go
when you die and you're waiting for the
Rapture I don't mean the Holy Spirit I
mean your individual spirits you know
they they are nights when people cannot
be present we deal with these things
over and over and over again number one
there is no such thing as a coming
rapture
none
the Bible doesn't say it
it is not true it was made up by some
religionists it is being perpetrated by
some good people
many of whom are sincere it is strictly
non-biblical
now if that's clear say Amen if you
think it's not true find me a text
it's not there
now having said that what just happened
to a man's Spirit the Bible tells us
very clearly that when a man dies he
returns to the dust and his Spirit
returns to God who gave it the word
spirit in the Old Testament comes from
Rock for in the New Testament comes from
Numa both of these words me and
Aya or wind or breath when God made man
he breathed into his nostrils the Breath
of Life Man became a living Soul he
didn't have a little soul he was a soul
you want to see a soul look at anybody
in here
We're All Souls
when you die what happened in the
beginning when God Gave You bread is
reverse the breath leaves you die you
return to the dust it's as simple as
that in job job chapter 27 and verse 3
job said all the while the spirit of God
was in my nostrils he was breathing air
spirit of God that's all you die it goes
when you're alive you got it
and you can't do without it long next
please
Pastor why did they say that the Sabbath
doesn't matter we have now heard the
truth what matters is that you
understand you've heard the truth when
somebody say Amen to that
the devil doesn't want you to know the
truth and he creates some people who are
very influential who will always tell
you it doesn't matter God says it does
who will believe God
I'd rather believe God trusts him and
you the Bible says if you keep the whole
law and you're offending one point
you're guilty of how much
that's James 2 10 and the Bible says
that sin is the transgression or
breaking of God's law First John 3 4 and
the Bible says the wages of sin is what
death so beloved listen to the word of
God make sure what you believe is
founded on the unquestionable authority
of God's word and stand there well I've
heard it I've had friends say it to me
oh Brooks Sabbath doesn't matter if it
doesn't matter why do they get so upset
when I preach it
next please
Dr Brooks this will have to be our last
question for tonight I heard you speak
of the time of the end and the end of
time please what is the difference
that's a good question and we've had it
before as a matter of fact last night
you read it on the screen the Bible
tells us that there is the time of the
end and the Bible says there is the end
of time and I have an old illustration
that answers that perfectly when I was a
boy and Thanksgiving was coming around
people used to buy live poetry is there
anybody here who knows about that
oh you know what I mean don't you you go
and you buy a turkey alive
you take him home and you put him in a
pen so he can't run around and run all
the fat off right
you give him plenty food
plenty water he doesn't have a care in
the world he thinks he's really living
but he's living in the time of the end
and then on Thanksgiving evening you go
out and you open the door and you catch
that Rascal by the neck and you drag him
out to the chopping block and when the
hatchet comes down that's the end of
time
so the time of the end is that period
immediately preceding the end of time
and that's where we are now
and some of us are being fattened up
things are going well we think having a
big time
but when the trumpet sounds
and the heavens reveal Christ that's the
end of time
it makes sense to prepare now
for the end of time during the time of
the end